you may not recognize Terri Jean Belaya
by his real name but you may recognize
him by his wrestling name
the Hulkster became a fixture of
American pop culture thanks the
popularity of the WWF which also opened
the door to his brief career in
Hollywood unfortunately Hollywood isn't
really calling Hogan like it did a few
decades ago thanks to a lengthy list of
controversies and complications standing
between Hogan and his glory days
here's why hollywood won't cast Hulk
Hogan anymore
Hogan exposed childhoods everywhere were
ruined when Gawker broke the story of a
sex tape involving Hogan and Playboy
Playmate Heather Cole the wife of
Hogan's friend Bubba the Love Sponge
Clem Cole would later testify that Hogan
was just one of the many men her husband
pressured her into sleeping with
although she insisted she had no idea
Clem was filming the encounter in a now
infamous twist however the leaked tape
would prove to be the undoing of Gawker
itself
Hogan filed a lawsuit against the news
site which was ordered to pay Hogan 31
million in damages and subsequently
forced to shut down in 2016 he was
willing to do whatever it took to take
down Gawker I knew we were doing what
was right and even if we would have lost
even if we would have lost it would have
been good because everybody would have
known what golfer was all about the
situation is almost bizarre enough to
warrant it based on a true story
Hollywood movie but even Hogan's own
true story probably wouldn't cast him
anymore
let me tell you something sister brother
you're gonna feel the tender embrace
hole camilia racist remarks in case you
missed it Hulk Hogan was officially
fired by the WWE in 2015 although some
said he voluntarily resigned the WWE
insisted it fired Hogan after a series
of racist comments he made were secretly
recorded and yet another leaked sex tape
with Heather Cole I mean I am a racist
to a point but then when it comes to
nice people in and whatever Hogan made a
public apology for his statement
claiming a statements didn't represent
his personal beliefs in a bid to
distance itself from Hogan
all mentions of him were scrubbed from
the official WWE website and online Hall
of Fame kind of a weird choice it's not
like everyone would suddenly forget he
was a major wrestling star for decades
not long after rumors began to circulate
that the WWE might be willing to bring
the wrestling legend back into the fold
scandals and all not so Hollywood Hulk's
work in Hollywood
despite literally calling himself
Hollywood Hulk Hogan he isn't exactly
impressive his first movie appearance
was a cameo in rocky 3 is a wrestler
named thunder lifts
thunder the sisters in the flesh favored
several years later
Hogan would make his star debut in the
cult classic no-holds-barred is a
popular wrestler named rip which was not
a dramatic stretch in any way no other
wrestler had made quite as big a splash
on the big screen at Oak except for
maybe Andre the Giant and Roddy Piper I
have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick ass
I'm all audible Oh still had a few more
movies than most and a TV series called
Thunder in paradise to his credit that
well went dry by the late 90s with Hulk
Hogan's last major role coming by way of
the ultimate weapon in 1998 that level
of cheesy action movie fare didn't
really survive through the early 2000s
leaving Hulk out in the cold a little
too real Hulk Hogan's attempted nepotism
also fell horribly flat first there was
the attempt to use his fame to help his
daughter Brooke watch a singing career
while she did have a few minor hits
Brooke made the mistake of being one too
many generic blonde pop singers during
the early 2000s and having a famous dad
named Hulk Hogan still wasn't enough to
stand out if that weren't enough Hogan
decided to follow in the footsteps of
The Osbournes
and put his questionable family on
reality TV Hogan Knows best began airing
in 2005 although the show was Simek
popular with wrestling fans the decision
to put his family in the spotlight
created unnecessary strain for everyone
involved in August 2007 Hulk's son Nick
was involved in a horrific car accident
and his best friend John Graziano was
severely injured Graziano was left with
permanent brain damage and will
reportedly spend the rest of his life in
a semi-conscious state the Graziano
family sued the Hogan's and the two
family settled out of court
while Nick spent just eight months in
jail a messy divorce in the immediate
aftermath of Nick's car crash Hulk Hogan
was left reeling when his wife Linda
filed for divorce by the time the dust
is a bitter divorce settled
Linda managed to leave her marriage with
about 70 percent of Hulk Hogan's well
Linda later blamed the divorce entirely
on her axe claiming she divorced him
after he'd had an affair with one of
their daughter's friends she even went
as far as to claim Hulk Hogan had an
intimate relationship with wrestler
Brutus Beefcake although she later
retracted those claims by 2008 Hogan
Knows best was canceled and Hulk was
devastated needless to say the wreck of
his personal life has kept him fairly
busy off screen at least he has is pasta
mania money to fall back on right yeah I
didn't so much
ah guru no Hugh I kind of feel hard big
bubble brother can Hulk return to
Hollywood given the negative press that
Hulk Hogan has experienced in recent
years it only makes sense that if he
were welcomed back into the WWE it would
be his bad guy it's certainly easier to
have everyone hate a sex tape closet
racist than to realistically turn such a
guy like that into a hero but who knows
a successful return to the WWE could
help open a back door that would help
Hulk Hogan he's his way back into
Hollywood it won't be easy but it's not
entirely possible the loans the man who
helped bring Hogan into Hollywood via
that rocky cameo has helped himself
another Hollywood action movie has been
staked kind of relevant thanks to his
Expendables movies maybe a future
project could make room for Hogan
whatever moves Hulk Hogan makes to
reignite his Hollywood career he'll have
to be careful he should know better than
anyone the cameras are always rolling
hopefully he can keep a lid on his
racist rant and was in the pan thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]